oh yeah i guess this is the first
podcast uh since i got married so yeah
congrats i'm i'm i'm a married man now
yeah yeah yeah
very nice yeah so i guess i guess now i
can ask what was okay sex i remember
before the marriage you were just like
oh yeah you know it's it's gonna is it
gonna be the jiu-jitsu kaisen of
marriages it's okay is it gonna be me
it's gonna be mid you know
how how was your guys's experiences with
it it was okay
sherry could never say
i could have been in my hotel room
watching jesus okay soon but you know it
had to come out no it wasn't that was
fantastic i mean like
yeah it was just uh
because i mean this is what like my
second or third
like wedding i've been to yeah is is
this your first like mates wedding you
guys have been to this is my second was
my first year but it was very different
to my first mates oh because it was the
indian wedding no no it was the japanese
wedding oh okay it was a very
traditional like you know [ __ ]
invite your boss and your colleagues
level yeah yeah yeah so like actually
this i'd say this was the first time
where it's like a proper like you know
mates
um i got really [ __ ] close to crying
watching you cry though yeah yeah i
thought because like in my head i was
like in my head i was like okay this is
a really [ __ ] momentous occasion for
god yeah you know obviously every
wedding very emotional yeah yeah really
important day for a lot of people right
and so like you know i'm
like you know i cried at my cousin's
wedding right right because obviously
like watching a family member cry is
gonna make you cry right but i didn't
cry my mates winning yeah right nothing
against my mate yeah i just did it
you're not good enough
but i was fully expecting that i was
going to cry at some point in your
wedding yeah but i didn't know what was
going to be the trigger yeah right and
definitely it and the trigger came very
quickly
when you started crying
because i don't know because there's
something about
watching gant cry that is like
really [ __ ] sad it's like seeing your
dad cry for the first yeah exactly it
just doesn't happen it doesn't happen it
never [ __ ] happens so when you see it
yeah in real life
it's just like oh [ __ ] yeah this is like
this is gonna make me cry and like i i
could tell that i wasn't the only one
because literally [ __ ] seventy
percent of that room was crying at that
moment as well that was like a sniffing
convention for a while
told me man
and then and then i cried and then i
almost cried a second time when we
it was that clip where we hung it out oh
man
so many [ __ ] wholesome moments from
that wedding i'm [ __ ] glad i'm
[ __ ] glad i'm happy i'm happy because
i'm glad that
everyone was it was just like a
happiness like [ __ ] gathering you
know everyone was just like good vibes
everyone was just happy it was good
vibes and that was before everyone got
like [ __ ] hammered and [ __ ] drunk
man holy [ __ ] dude some people got
blasted there melin melin melin right
all right how many i remember melin so
we had we had an open bar
uh
and i remember best and worst decision
ever best and worst decision of my life
because i remember going up to the bar
to open the bar and you have to put like
a tab down on the bar and i remember
asking how much should i you know how
much is like a reasonable number right
to uh to to put the tab down uh and the
guy says like you know we've been doing
weddings for years we recommend this
number great and so i was like great
just in case i'm gonna put double the
amount so that i don't have to like get
charged so you don't have to call me if
if it like breaks that limit so i'm like
great and so how it works is that
however much you don't spend
uh they'll refund you so about like a
few days after the wedding i give them
an email to be like oh great can i get
the refund please how much was not on
was not used on the tab yeah and
i waited a few days because it was like
bank holiday or something and then i get
an email probably accessing all this
[ __ ] transactions yeah i get an email
back and they're like oh great uh we can
refund you a grand total of one pound
forty
legit one pound one pound forty
and i'm like damn yeah i'm like i'm not
even mad anymore i'm just impressed
you're like meticulously calculated yeah
but it was like double the recommended
amount and you guys [ __ ] destroyed
that and i'm not surprised because like
i've never seen so many [ __ ] shots
being taken out in like one night i'd
say like i'm i took around like seven
shots of tequila that night my god melin
was a [ __ ] tequila fiend my god if
you had become if you
went into like a five meter radius of
melind you are getting dragged to do a
shot of tequila i remember like there's
one time i remember seeing melin like
ask joey if she if you wanted the shot
and you're like no no million i hate
shots and she [ __ ] gave you a [ __ ]
death grip yeah and just dragged you to
the bar and made you do a shot she
literally grabbed me by my sleeve and
was just like
no it's not an answer
that's how i did that first shot and i
was like
so okay so the first shot was like all
right you know what it's it's it's a
wedding there's like seven other people
doing the show with me [ __ ] yeah you
know i hate tequila
so much yeah but i'll do it just because
i don't wanna you're vibing yeah it's
good i wanna be part of the vibe right
so i did it
it was [ __ ] horrible and then the
second time around was when melee was
like no it's not an answer and gra
dragged me to the bar yeah again with
all the familiar faces like oh the first
time for you all right yeah so i did the
second shot hated it and then a couple
of hours passed by and i'm like okay
alien hasn't called me back yet and so
just when i thought i was in the clear
mailing from a distance [ __ ] scottish
towards me
and it was just like tequila shot joey
and i just had to go
[ __ ] off
i literally i literally flipped a finger
i was just like no
get away from me and and i just walked
off amelie
because i thought because i knew if i
wasn't like stern about it yeah she
would grab me by the slave again yeah
because i heard from a bunch of other
people who were like way too nice to me
yeah they were like yes you made me do
like six shots and i'm like that's
because you have to say the hard note
you have to say it's not just the
software it's the hard note yeah
predator
yeah did you make you do any shots i
think so i didn't really mind though
one's fine yeah you only got to do one i
think melanie only made me do one what
did you make me do like three just
because you were just too close to her
vicinity-wise yeah yeah so i was really
worried because you know we had food and
i was like this isn't enough it's not
like
three courses gone yeah
i'm a six course kind of guy minimum or
at least give me someone else's course
who didn't finish right yeah and then
and then lord behold sp people just
start bringing out pizza yeah we we go
we go oh you could eat pizza it go it
was like all we can eat like stone baked
pizza yeah i i think i had like four
whole pizzas
i had a i had a worrying amount of pizza
it was like it was more pizza than any
doctor would ever recommend yeah like
even if you were like carb loading for
like a desert survival for like 10 weeks
you wouldn't eat then this many calories
this was i i don't know every time they
brought it to me i was like well i can't
say no i mean it's a different topping i
gotta try it that was me with the
espresso martinis oh yeah i think i had
like five espresso and i'm like oh
that's why i'm shaking yeah so we had a
station to uh give out free espresso
martinis to everyone wow yeah
i mean we wanted everyone to have a good
time like oh no one of that tab was
high no that wasn't even on the
that was like a free package that we
paid for i remember i remember i was
like i went up to the bar after like my
first espresso martini that they brought
out for everyone right and i was like oh
can i get another espresso martini and
the dude literally just points to the
side because there's literally this like
three layered shelf of espresso martinis
there was like 12 espresso martinis i
was like take your pick yeah i was like
oh [ __ ] all right cool
well i just drank like three of them and
i was just [ __ ] shaking yeah so i
guess like to go to like the start of my
experience of the wedding because
obviously you guys's experience was very
very different from mine yeah oh yeah so
like
um so we had like about i think it was
only like 62 people at this wedding so
it's like a fairly small wedding but
like i really really like the size of
the wedding because it was a good amount
of size i could keep up with like pretty
much you could interact with everyone i
could talk with everyone and not feel
like it was just like a convention
experience where i was having like one
sentence conversation with people but
like have proper meaningful
conversations which is which is good
because i just wanted to like i just
wanted to just like share the good vibes
and everything like that
um but i remember like the night before
the wedding i was so [ __ ] i don't
know i don't know what the right word to
describe it was it was like a mixture of
like nervous and excited because like it
was it was not like the bad kind of
nervous like the way i described it was
it kind of felt like you were 10 years
old and it was the day before christmas
and like you know you knew
you knew you were getting that n64 for
christmas you you knew that this was
like the special christmas well you were
getting the the [ __ ] game concert
yeah of course and so i i did not get
like i got like two hours of sleep
before my wedding before the day for my
wedding because i thought because i
tried to go to sleep at a reasonable
time so i was going to go to sleep at
around 11 00 and like i'm like great i'm
gonna have a reasonable amount of sleep
before my wedding can be well rested and
then like an hour passes two hour passes
and i'm like i cannot get to sleep okay
okay if i go to sleep now
i'll get six hours of sleep now
now
an hour passes all right five hours of
sleep now that's how it always works now
and i'll just like if if
i just go to sleep now i'll wake up and
i'm gonna have a wife you know it's
gonna be break and then it gets to about
four or five in the morning and i'm like
i'm like trying to i'm like trying to
like i'm in pure copium right now
because i'm just like what if i just
have no sleep before my wedding i can
function right if i just if i just stay
up all night i can function right that's
that's something i can do before like
one of the most important days of my
life i can do that but like before i
like truly justify to myself i'm like
okay let's just try something new so i
like
i i take off all of my sheets and take
all my blankets and i put them on the
floor i'm like let's let's try sleeping
on the floor on the hard floor and for
some reason i don't know if it's just
like these like asian jeans or something
where it just felt like i was home again
and i just like immediately conked out
oh my god
yeah i don't know right like i was
reminded of your monk days like sleeping
on the table
pretty much
it felt like i was sleeping along like a
[ __ ] futon or something i don't know
what it was about sleeping on the floor
but like i just immediately conked out
after like sleeping on like a nice comfy
bed or something um and then yeah like
we go to the vetting uh the wedding
venue and of course it was i was
not like tense nervous it was like the
feeling of like before you get in you
start a panel or you go on stage or
something yeah it's just like you know
this big thing is coming up but you just
gotta wait around yeah for it to start
that's the worst yeah it's it's i was i
was so i was so [ __ ] jittery
and i know yeah like because i talked to
sydney if she was nervous for the
wedding and she was like her nerves like
ended the moment she woke up because she
was like so busy like before the wedding
started because she had to like go do
her makeup go do her hair and like all
the bridesmaids as well so she was at
the
venue from like 9 00 a.m oh wow and i
didn't i didn't need to get there until
12 00
to 12 noon you're the easy job yeah
and so like that that was just like a
lot of time for just me to like be alone
with my own thoughts and be really
really [ __ ] nervous um
and so yeah i was i was really tense
nervous whatever but luckily luckily i
had i had my i had my boys with me i had
my boys lads were there the lads were
there my hype men you know were they
were there with me um and i remember i'm
like i remember um
going to the boys um so
to to fully explain neither of these two
were were my best men uh it's it's okay
so
i'm sorry i'm sorry guys and uh only
connor was a groomsman but like part of
the reason was like it made me realize
how long it's been since i've planned
this wedding because we had we like me
and cindy had planned the wedding
basically like before we had moved to
japan yeah and yeah and like every like
air like every role or like the the
entire wedding party was chosen and
everything um yeah and it was like it
was like going the wedding was going to
originally be before trash taste even
started yeah so it's like [ __ ] insane
that like i've grown so much closer to
these two in like these past two years
where like
when my wedding was planned i like i i
knew joey but we we'd hung out only like
a few times you know and we'd hang out
like a lot but i was like not as close
to you as i am now so so it was like it
was so weird
to like
it was so weird to have a wedding that
was planned two years ago where like now
the dynamic is like totally [ __ ]
different and everything i was just in
the crabby like
so like i remember like we called
everyone in to the main ceremony hall uh
so everyone starts getting their seats
and like i call like i'm like i go out i
go out by myself
and i'm like gone you got this you got
this go on this is you're gonna you're
gonna do a no-tier wedding run there's
going to be zero crying at this wedding
i'm like i got to myself just to give
myself like a breather and like i'm like
okay i bring out like we have me and
cindy had personal vows so i bring out
my personal vows and i'm like rehearsing
them in my head i'm like okay you got
this this is zero tears we're not going
to cry this morning we got this you got
this i read like the first sentence and
i just like started like [ __ ] like
my jaw my george starts going
and i'm like oh no oh no this is a bad
sign this is a bad sign
and so while while i'm like
while i'm doing this like all of my all
my lads all my groomsmen come out and
they see me and i'm like guys i'm going
to use some hype around me i'm i'm i'm
going to need some [ __ ] hype around
me yeah and so
like this was a step this was the moment
where i took a page out of connor's book
i'm like i literally go full monkey mode
right outside the ceremony it works dude
it works i was like i was like ugh you
[ __ ] got this you [ __ ] got this
not realizing that everyone in the site
could you hear me like just [ __ ]
shouting but i like i heard you shouting
at something but i i wasn't too sure i
was like
that's good right like people who fear
this the shouting type you are but
people who haven't tried it if you if
you've tried it actually works yeah you
fully commit to it yeah it works yeah i
mean like that time it really [ __ ]
worked because i had so much adrenaline
in my body yeah that uh that i needed
some way to uh i need i needed some way
to release it yeah and so i remember
getting to the ceremony room and i'm
like okay it's good the shouting helps
i'm like i'm like i'm like reset on the
chatting's help uh i go to i go to the
front i turn around
i look at my mum's face and just
immediately
immediately i'm just like i i'm a broken
man again
because like oh just
like my cousin told me this after the
ceremony yeah but he's just like if
there's one thing you definitely should
not do when you're standing up there
waiting is your mob is look at your mom
it's look at your parents and it's true
i i can understand that yeah let's go
because
it's a feeling i can't describe where
you know my dad and my mom were like
[ __ ] tearing up and i rarely see them
tear up and it's just
it's just like i i don't know like
what did my face look like when i was
waiting up there i got i gotta know
because i i can do a reenactment of
exactly what you were like you're like
that's what you look like close yeah
that's pretty accurate it's just like
every now and then you'd like to be like
oh yeah
that's what you look like
right before